Alright it is time to go to the game awards 2017. Hello Edie where's Jenna hello
Jenna hello suzi I'm very excited for the show I'll be presenting today
For an award and it's a student award, which is actually really cool. There's Matt
We've got Larry over there
Are you - oh you - I want to say I love you guys first of all I'm really excited to see you
I've not seen her in forever really sorry have a great night were you sitting I'm not sure I don't know either
I didn't we've got we know we're inside you're gonna watch the you're gonna watch the event we're gonna have some fun
What do you what are you hoping with grief and punching not yet? I'm waiting
Okay, next week
next box walk
Like the biggest names are here
Tell me about your new League of Legends team means you've seen took a photo together, we didn't want to cherish it forever cool
It's good out here welcome to Twitter, thank you so much well. Can you look at work there welcome to welcome you to Twitter
Yes after it said we are alive like very soon as can you make sure you're presenting
Good luck I won't keep you, but by spitting into the theatre
Vlogging on my iPhone today because I forgot an SD card and my camera was dead two things
To fail here's Jenna hi Jenna
She's getting the drink
The Game Awards Orchestra tonight
This is the show that we've always dreamed of doing the game words they keep all so much for joining us
We are here to celebrate the greatest storm ever taken the world that's video games in order to do it
style tonight
Alive
We're now backstage the game rewards about to present, and I'm so excited because I present an ecstatic okay?
He's only who that is you got to a quick Google search because you will immediately
Know he is so incredible, and he's avala in death too. He's by far the best voice actor
I just I'm such a huge fan
I'm kind of and girly right now
And he was also agent oils in French one of my favorite shows ever so about that employer, so
Vangelis from the show let's say clip the world
The person that request
The winner and the beer selected by 51 mobile media news outlets and the fans to be your newest to
The legend of ZOA
The show is over it was so awesome
surprise game of the year was Zelda
That was who I was hoping for but it's such a hard decision because I loved Super Mario Odyssey so much
We could have two winners in my book
We are at the after party and there is Mc Donalds.
So Matt is gonna be very, very, very happy
Cheeseburger for Everybody!
We have a very special performance coming up appreciate this next artist flying in all the way from Australia
I think there dizzyland right to be here tonight bass gentleman
Charli XCX
So it's after the Game Awards and oh my goodness
He'll see hi so this is Yossi, and he is the sweetest little pup and his best friend is me
Oh, hi there, so the game Wars was so much fun Matt to have a good time. I had an absolute blast
Cheeseburgers at the after-party what more can I ask for show us your new lens, let's talk about it
So it's a 16 by 35 2.8 Sony G master, or my a 7s mark - so is a 16 - yes
It's a 16 to 35. This lens is what Justine and I have been using for many many years now. It's my favorite
It's got really great. Yeah. It's a 4.0. Though. So this has more depth. It's summer. It's $2,100, but it's a great lens
I'm very much looking forward to trying it out, but it's very heavy weight. Let me hold it let me see
Yeah, do it. It's so heavy and look at his microphone. He has what is this is absurd it's a rechargeable microphone. No
It's powered by its own power source you charge this microphone with a micro USB. It's just rechargeable Wow okay?
Well I made fun of you, but now I'm gonna get one
Should we open up Maddy's Christmas present so?
A lot of you guys may know because most of the jewelry that I wear is Tiffany's and I'm a huge Tiffany's fan
I've been a fan of Tiffany's for basically ever they now had dog collars Madi
Josie your present look. It's in here. What's in Mandy. You just want the ribbon. What's in here? Hey?
You're the worst Christmas gift ever well. I guess I probably could have
Oh, my gosh still loving it
Well I think mommy's more excited about this and doggy well, they're into the dream
Official unboxing oh, it's cute. Oh my god, beautiful Wow if they made this in a bracelet for a human
Oh, yeah, I'm adding you into it. Yes my prayer got tricked
This is only when you're dressing up and wearing your fancy your Sunday finest oh
man, that'd be cute if this could customize to their own little tag -
Pretty little information. Do you like it say? Thank you?
Maddy you look handsome little tighter